Lisa quails here and it is so funny
watching people walk by this Xbox one
exclusive DLC and try to read the name
okay I'm gonna try alright it's ultra
super Dead Rising 3
arcade remix hyper edition X plus alpha
I think that's right I don't know if I
do I think I think they're all scrambles
around
alright let's go out harass people in
the booth and see see what they think of
the game see what they think of the DLC
you know killing zombies and whatnot
alright alright who are we gonna pick
who's my victim excuse me sir can I talk
to you about this game that means you
have to pause I know like I'm making you
stop play the game in order to talk to
you about it are you big Dead Rising fan
no not really
I'm the right and wrong person to talk
to you're the perfect person are but
you're a zombie killing fan like you
don't want zombies to win indeed right
how is it how does it feel it's
fantastic really fun just started off to
start playing lots of mayhem lots of
destruction fun characters currently
playing hacker from final fight which is
really fun I hadn't seen him in a while
but yeah good stuff so where are you
right now you're in some kind of
graveyard kind of graveyard we started
off in the city and then we're rolling
through a graveyard pretty much
destroying anything undead in our path
at this point yeah somebody else kick
some zombie by time can't we're counting
on you as a human race alright got
headphones on they probably can't hear
me alright you know what we're gonna
squeeze in here oh we're gonna go this
way
alright Dead Rising here we are in this
can you just say the name for me real
quick super ultra Dead Rising 3 arcade
remix hyper edition ii x plus oh it took
me like three times to try to say it's
okay if you don't get it I didn't get it
I was sweating bullets in the hotel room
last night I'm like there's no way I'm
going to remember that and somehow you
just kind of wake up and you do it and
it's okay
I'm proud of you come Vancouver and we
worked on Dead Rising 2 & 3 and this is
our new ape crazy wonderful over-the-top
hyper insane arcade version basically
this is what happens when developers get
bored you know we turned it up to like a
thousand everything is redone all the
graphics are redone and it's just this
wonderful arcade experience game is
already pretty over the top like it's
it's kind of crazy so which makes the
ceiling is right there and it's like
poke poke poke boom and now we're like
way up there somewhere because we've got
all the characters from the Dead Rising
Universe dressed up in the most
uncomfortable strange and delicious
cosplay you could imagine I see that so
what's uh where is he right now where is
this guy and this is a section from Dead
Rising 3 fans would be you know familiar
with this area but it is so over the top
redressed over the top redress that it's
almost not recognizable anymore Dead
Rising 3 were so proud of Dead Rising 3
but it was a serious tone visually we
got a little bit of slack about that we
knew we were hiding all the funny so
once people got in there the funny is
still intact the banana hammocks were
unleashed unfortunately you know last
year this takes it to a whole new level
so we have agar hear from final fight
but it's Frank from the original dead
riser and so he's dressed up so it's
cosplay which is kind of now the cosplay
thing has just taken off and everything
is arcade and all the power-ups and all
the sounds and the tastes like if you
were playing in the late 80s and the 90s
you're gonna put the headphones on
you're gonna get that little that little
chill that little giggle because it's
even the announcer is like over the top
and it's like so it's silly some other
costumes so basically there's a whole
truckload of costumes but my favorite is
Nick dressed up as Felicia from
Darkstalkers and if anyone knows
Darkstalkers Felicia is the beautiful
Catwoman absolutely another one is Annie
we had to you know support the women we
needed a chicken there so she's dressed
up as chun-li I have such a huge crush
on chun-li so we have chun-li in our
game even better if you dress up as
those people you get those moves
from the arcade which of course not dead
rising 3 whatsoever so you're doing like
Hadouken Xin in the mall in destroying
zombies and with you know Ryu's spin
kick and it's just like what am I
looking at and that's the point my
favorite games to make fun of I love it
Darkstalkers I can't wait I like the big
big believer the game should be fun
should be over-the-top so any closing
words play our game it's available now
we announced and dropped and that's what
we should do we announced yesterday and
it was available that night we are just
so loving on the Twitterverse people
talking about it I think it caught
everyone off guard and that's the whole
point
have fun thank you so much alright
Twitterverse tell me what you think at
least Foyle's use hashtag GameSpot III
we're gonna keep walking around the Xbox
booth